please welcome nicole lapin
thank you for doing this
you stress the importance of financial
independence for women and
why is that personal for you so i didn't
come from money as you know i grew up in
an immigrant family i started as a
poetry major drew so if i could do this
literally anyone can do this and so i
realized that it's actually not that
complicated and it became my mission to
take the jargon out of this because i
think that's what makes it so scary and
so taboo do you have to realize that
money is a language just like anything
else if you go to japan and you don't
speak japanese you'd be really confused
but then if you speak the language you
can understand it and join the
conversation the same thing with money
if you go to wall street and you don't
speak the language of money you'll be
really confused but here's the thing you
can't budget your way into wealth you
can't even save your way into wealth
those are great things your base salary
is not even going to grow you long-term
wealth the only thing that will is
investing and utilizing that amazing
force of compound interest that has so
often been used against us in the
financial system with credit cards and
mortgages where it snowballs out of
control well you can take that control
back and use it in your favor well what
is the first step
start
now
you don't need a lot of money to make a
lot of money if you tell yourself that
those are just stories you're telling
yourself you need the most time possible
einstein calls this the eighth wonder of
the world where compound interest your
money literally makes money for you not
doing anything you don't need to look at
stock charts all day you just have to
set it and forget it and honestly today
is as good a day as any you're never as
young as you are today actually that's
an important point is age age matters it
absolutely matters
i'm glad i didn't invest earlier said no
one ever
all right well we actually had some
audience questions our first question
comes from diamond by the way best name
ever
hi drew and nicole
i'm a mom of two little ones ages 3 and
10 months
how do i get them to become financially
literate grown-ups
okay that's a little young
however when you hear a question like
that what goes through your mind and
what's your advice
the reality is our kids are not learning
this stuff in school if i were in charge
of the world it would be different so
it's incumbent on us as parents to help
our kids become financially illiterate
and you can implement little concepts
like if your kids want to borrow money
for you for a bit from you for a big
purchase you can charge them interest if
they pay late you can have an allowance
go on a sliding scale or have them
negotiate for an allowance or even ask
them how much a car costs this is a
fascinating conversation with a kid by
the way to give them a concept of how
much things cost
but here's the reality diamond wherever
you are
it doesn't matter if you are not
financially in control your kiddos are
watching you a lot of our financial
habits and mores happen from our parents
whether they spent frivolously they were
out of control they hoarded they coupon
clip they got into debt so your kids are
watching you you have to put your oxygen
mask on first even before helping your
kiddos because they're copying every
financial move you make our next
question comes from brittany in our
audience uh brittany
so my question is as someone who's in
the last year of their 20s what should i
be doing to be financially successful in
my 30s you have the luxury of time you
don't need a lot of money to start if
you have that much time so for easy map
let's say you put 100 bucks into
an index fund that tracks the market if
you started at 25 by the time you're 65
you'd have a million bucks if you start
at 35 and that's only 12 000 of a
difference right 100 bucks a month times
12 months a year times 10
you would have 300 000 when you're 65
that's a 700 000 difference just based
on compound interest so start today i
definitely will thank you okay
i've never heard anything like that so
you take a hundred dollars a month if
you have
the privilege of that kind of money and
you invested in an s p
500
for
most of your life by the end there will
be something there for you yes and with
each year and each decade that will
decrease
over time we want to beat inflation
right we've been hearing all these
headlines about inflation which is about
three percent so you at least need to
inflation-proof your money what are you
getting in a bank account right now or a
checking account that's what a lot of
women put their money
less than a percent if inflation's at
three percent you're losing two percent
of your purchasing power so inflation is
just stuff costing more tomorrow than it
did
yesterday so when little drew was going
to a movie how much did it cost
two dollars and fifty cents how much
does it cost today
it's about seventeen dollars a person at
this point and then that doesn't even
count for the candy counter right and if
you transport little drew with her two
dollars and fifty cents she's not
getting into a movie and that's why you
have to make your money work for you you
work so hard for your money it's time it
returned the favor so over time the
market or the s p 500 which tracks the
market gets you about seven percent
inflation adjusted your book is just
so incredible because numbers can be
overwhelming finances can be so
stressful but you talk about the human
experience as well as give such sound
financial advice so you're who i want to
be following and nothing makes me
happier than seeing people succeed so
guess what everyone in the audience is
going home with a copy of nicole's book
thank you nicole miss independent a
simple 12-step plan to start investing
and grow your own wealth is available
right now now we all have it and you can
too go buy it we'll be right back
[Music]